[Music]
so my organization decided to migrate
sql server to the cloud and utilize more
in azure
i knew i would have to learn azure and
its services
the course i took was simply learn got
me more freelance projects as well so
i'm very happy i took this course
hi my name is cody mayhew i live in
colorado and i upskilled with the simply
learns azure's master's cloud architect
program
i joined the department of veteran
affairs 12 years ago and i've been on
the repository team for the last four
years
last year they decided to migrate sql
server to the cloud
and for me that meant i would have to
learn and take a course in cloud
architecture it has opened the door for
so many other things and opportunities
i'm a big sports fan i do a couple
different things i run some podcasts and
i do some website development which i
was actually outsourcing and paying for
these services that was causing high
monthly subscription fees
migrating that to the cloud now i can
control and do it all myself this allows
me to save money and create my own brand
i'm truly grateful for that
simply learn has made my life a lot
simpler